pas et bien maintenant on va parler de
michel foucault avec avec jean-daniel
donc michel foucault qui est mort cette
semaine à l'âge de 58 ans alors vous qui
le connaissez très bien j'en ai les
secousses a dit qu'il était qu'il était
gravement malade parce que c'était la
stupéfaction
ses amis le savaient de plus ils ont
donc pas plus oui parce que là si on a
été absolument c'est tombé le jour où
quelques lignes dans la presse en disant
qu'il était gravement malade il ya un
petit très petit nombre d'amis dont je
ne suis pas allé ce qui le savait depuis
peut-être un peu plus longtemps sont des
gens comme son éditeur et ami pierre
nora comme vous savez l'ue a importé les
deux livres qui venait de sortir à
l'hôpital il en a pris dans l'après
connaissance à l'aube dans les derniers
jours
bon vous avez connu michel foucault
alors vous le publier un article dans le
nouvel observateur cette semaine nous
vous racontez votre sentiment sur les
gens vous font les autres et moi qui
parle bien entendu mais j'ai fait venir
parce que vous le vous l'avez connu ou
vont vous avez lu ses livres puis en
même temps vous avez partagé ses
batailles politiques bien entendu bon
qu'est ce que moi j'ai l'impression que
michel foucault
il a inventé une autre manière d'être un
intellectuel dans le siècle
en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils voulaient et
ça ça lui ferait plaisir mais je suis
content que vous le disais que vis-à-vis
de la télévision moi ça m'a posé des
problèmes puisque ville avait des
rapports assez compliqué il a jamais
accepté de parler de lui mais voilà
parle anglais ici même mais c'est vrai
ce que vous dites est vrai bien une
chose qu'on peut dire aussi sur le
autrement c'est que avant de venir par
hasard j'ai voulu voir
j'ai consulté le
les mémoires d'un autre très grand
intellectuel que vous avez reçue c'est
raymond aron et ses mémoires en 727 page
soleil à l'index à la famille j'ai pris
la lettre bref
je ne vous connais pas j'ai trouvé
extraordinaire
ces deux grands intellectuels que dans
les pensées les bureaux du centre
croisés et non s'entrecroiser sans
s'imprégner sens influencé s'infléchir
au point que au moment de faire le bilan
de ce qui a compté pour lui car on ne le
suit pas et ça fait la singularité de
foucauld passerait en même temps vous
avez ce matin gilles deleuze et qui a
été un de ses amis et qui est un de ses
plus proches qui d'ailleurs une seule je
lui parle le mieux de lui et bien disais
c'est un des plus grands philosophes de
tous les temps je n'ai pas la compétence
pour leur part jugé les georges dumézil
dit c'est un des hommes probablement les
plus intelligents que j'aie jamais
rencontré
et puis le silence de harengs il y avait
d'ailleurs ces deux univers et était
éloigné au point que une anecdote me
vient que tu ne fais pas partie du
déroulement d'un sujet mais fou qu'on
m'avait raconté que sortant du collège
de france et ce terme et 68 jeunes y
avait une foule de policiers un petit
peu trop grande aux yeux au bout de fou
cours et causse veut dire tant d'années
c'est céline ces préoccupations le les
gens qui devaient qu'il est censé devant
être réprimés étaient peu nombreux pas
inquiétant et et ça se passait trop de
pas trop mal non enfin foucault dia
aaron hill sorti l'été comme un collègue
ouvrier de france en plus cette union
ayant concédé moi mais c'est un peu
beaucoup et aaron très énervé lui très
m les universitaires marché et
protecteur lui mais mon cher vous ne
serez jamais guéri l'état doit se
défendre alors faut qu'on m'a dit c'est
curieux j'ai pas osé lui répondre en
intimider par je ne sais quoi aaron et
avril et bojan oui pour moi c'était pour
moi je veux dire reconstituant les
d'ailleurs archi ce sont des sinon c'est
la programmation au sommet et foucault
dit alors que je savais que je devais
lui dire la ratification du fait que tu
as accompli l'hégélianisme de fait
accompli
non j'avais passé les deux univers qui
sont extraordinaires et pourquoi je vous
raconte ça c'est parce que l'univers de
foucault a été libérée c'est
exceptionnel d'abord on peut dire qu'il
a marqué d année sans qu'une génération
se reconnaissent en lui entre 60 et 80
il régnait et sans avoir de véritable
disciple il influencé 120 ans une
véritable école
c'était un et il écrivait de langue
somptueuse ces structures de décider
philosophique c'est des symphonies dans
le sens des grandes ouvertures de la
reprise des thèmes des conclusions point
d'orgue c'est une langue
comment ils changent nordique d'ailleurs
selon les livres il change aussi
c'est c'est un énorme artiste il a sa
place je veux dire dans une émission non
philosophique parce que l'art avec
lequel est composé les mots et les
choses c'est à mon avis quelque chose
qui devra encore être étudiées hors de
son contexte philosophique et en même
temps c'était une sorte de super six
insidieux le classicisme somptueux de sa
langue
le caractère bénédictin de ces études
montré très peu le caractère le pouvoir
subversif perturbateur de sa pensée
parce qu il a mis en cause pratiquement
toutes les méthodes de penser quelque
part en gros
il annoncé ça fait un petit peu si vous
voulez la vulgate de son succès il
annoncé ce qu'on appelait la mort du
sujet bon la civilisation occidentale
avait régné pendant un certains nombres
de siècle parce qu'il appelait le
discours les mots dans le livre les mots
et les choses les mauvais perdants du
volet l'air du temps il est logique
dominante la vulgate la mode aussi et
puis un moment donné les choses sont
apparus et dont on a vu qu'elles ne
dépendent pas des mots du discours
aignan et à partir de ce moment là à la
suite de ce qui a été prononcé par
nietzsche vraiment de dieu tout le monde
dit le fou quoi je suivais en disant
c'est la mort de l'homme et dense est
dans cette travée dans ces strates dont
il faisait comme ils disaient
l'archéologie mais l'auteur de beaucoup
de manques sont passés qui sont à la
mode qui est logique archéologiques
espaces béants ce discours
ils sont tous les maux qui sont victimes
on est opéré par tout le monde sans le
savoir
et à partir de cet univers de
singularité si on nous fait seul
autorisé à changer lui-même il va dire
chose antilles aronian par excellence
pour continuer ce que disait au début il
va dire travailler c'est entreprendre de
penser autrement
après qu'avant il va dire l'intellectuel
s'est pas seulement à leur présenter de
modifier la pensée des autres mais la
sienne propre
il va être dans cet espace mouvant
jamais où on l'attend toujours un autre
point et il va avoir une sorte de
mobilité philosophique que j'ai sur
laquelle je veux pas m'étendre ici et ça
marche bien d'ailleurs dans nos sens
depuis huit ans mais qui va contraster
qui va faire se poser que des questions
avec ses engagements politiques puisque
on va trouver sa signature au bout de
tous les manifestes ou le manifeste
libertaire il est par essence contre les
pouvoirs contre tous les pouvoirs et
d'ailleurs avec même avec ce pouvoir
on peut être pas dire qu'il était temps
enfin lui disant vite et arrco pitre et
puis je vais pouvoir d'utiliser
des mots je pouvais y remédier ok boucle
serait pas possible sans sa philosophie
et libertaire tous azimuts il a été au
fond à la recherche de tous les points
de rupture d'une société s'il était bien
que dans les limites dans les frontières
dans ce qu'ils faisaient les charnières
mais au fond un des livres moi que je
préfère c'est souvent le 10 mai parce
qu'il est annonciateur de tellement de
choses c'est le premier c'est l'histoire
de folie aux classiques
[ __ ] quand les pays après sa livre
d'ailleurs qui a été publié par un autre
marginal de l'histoire c'est philippe
ariès et l'as roma était pas reconnu il
ya 80 ans qui avait été refusé dans une
grande maison d'édition par quelqu'un
que j'ai bien connu d'ailleurs pour
lequel j'avais d'admiration qui était
barrages
oui c'est les débuts de foucauld n'ont
pas été les américains ne s'y sont pas
trompés ils ont publié en abrégé
aussitôt l'édition de l'histoire
d'affoler et je ne sais pas si on a le
temps de résumer les torts de folie mais
je veux dire c'est un peu c'est assez
saisissant parce que par ces simples
dans l'exposé et puisque ça va se
ramifier dans des univers incroyable
pétillant perturbateurs dérangeant on
puisse avoir des effets il remarque
pendant tout le moyen âge les fous
n'était pas vraiment exclu pourquoi
parce qu'ils étaient mélangés aux
clochards aux délinquants aux parias et
que même dans un certain sens dans la
mythologie le fou avait peut-être une
fonction comme le fou du village change
jean prince mychkine porteur de vérité
inspiré jean même foulure au chaud
durant la nuit et puis tout d'un coup on
découvre la pensée asilaire c'est à dire
que croyant être dans un modernisme
scientifique en isole les fous et on
invente l'asile en vente en même temps
la psychiatrie d'ailleurs c'est la
naissance de la psychiatre mais en
inventant l'asile on enferme dit-il
doublement à la fois danse ont lieu dans
sa prison à zinder et dans son exclusion
de fou puisqu'on le décret de malade
mental
et à partir de ce moment l'année en
grand clivage c'est le grand clivage
toujours le discours les mots et les
choses et dans ce clivage y voyant de
naissance alors on va il va y avoir une
grande réputation faite à à foucault
contre les cavistes et battre à savoir
la confusion de mai 68 le savoir c'est
le pouvoir ait dit non puisque à
certains moments la prison l'asile a
enfermé mais de la psychiatrie avant et
des méthodes anatomique qui n'aurait pas
eu lieu sans elle alors il est toujours
en deçà et à revers de ce qu'on pouvait
attendre
mais on peut dire que ce dans la
sexualité le beau aussi d'un succès
reste encore en deçà au fond ils
découvrent que la grande distinction
dans l'antiquité et dans la civilisation
n'existe pas entre les terreaux et
l'homosexuel entre la façon d'accepter
ou de réprimer la sexualité
bon alors on va le voir et l'entendre il
se trouve jean daniel que michel
foucault avait accepté de venir et
l'émission apostrophes c'est indécent de
76 d une émission qui est curieux parce
qu'elle est faite au louvre c'était pas
pourquoi mais au début ils avaient
vieilli depuis finalement deux jours
avant les dialogues qui n'en peut plus
parler de veille étaient un peu
compliqués un très bon il a dit non
évidemment je peux plus parler de mon
livre je veux pas elle était venue
parler d'un livre qui était paru à
l'époque qui avait fait beaucoup de
bruit qui étaient les minutes du procès
dr stern ou en union soviétique
alors il en avait admirablement parler
et puis
vous allez voir et
vers la fin de l'émission je fais
remarquer que s'il y avait 10 ans qui
avait publié les moins les choses à voir
ce qu'il va faire le jeu de la mort
c'est pour lacombe besoin pour publier
les mots et les choses et il ya juste
dix ans et vous écriviez l'homme enfin
non pour l'émission c'est la fin l'homme
n'est pas le plus vieux problème ni le
plus constant qu'ils soient posées au
savoir humain et ajouter un vrai livre
dans toute la page nos fins l'homme est
une invention dont l'archéologie de
notre pensée montre aisément la date
récente et peut-être la fin prochaine
oui parce qu'il m'a semblé en effet que
le moment où l'homme avait commencé à
devenir un problème à la fois
philosophique mais également technique
politique économique pollution pour lui
même ce moment n'était pas aussi ancien
qu'on pouvait l'imaginer
bon bien sûr il ya des rameuses et
traditionnelles questions que nous
connaissons si vous voulez moi je crois
que à partir d'un certain moment qu'on
peut situer entre la fin du xvième
siècle et début du 19ème il s'est passé
un phénomène important même c'est que
l'homme a cessé d'être immédiatement
dominé par les grandes menaces de la
mort c'est à dire par les menaces des
épidémies des familles les formidables
ravages de la mortalité infantile et que
l'homme en quelque sorte disposer les
sociétés humaines
je parle uniquement d'ailleurs de
l'occident mais c'est là où les choses
se sont noués que les sociétés
occidentales ont commencé à disposer
d'une espèce de marge de survie à partir
duquel l'homme est devenu relativement
disponible par rapport à ces urgences
fondamentale de ces grandes menaces de
la mort qui avait traversé ce d'histoire
jusque là et alors c'est à partir de ce
moment là il a fallu en quelque sorte à
la fois utilisées et mettre en question
essayer de problématiser l'homme en tant
qu il pouvait être disponible d'où la
question qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on va en
faire comment l'appliquer à appliquer
cet individu est bien à la croissance
des forces productives comment les
disciplines et comment construire des
grands
politiques et des reins et je crois
qu'on a eue là toute une technologie de
l'homme qui s'est développé à partir de
la question est ce que cette question
sera durera autant que l'humanité
peut-être peut-être pas voilà donc
c'était michel foucault vous dites dans
votre camp deux choses peut-être
rapidement
d'abord le courage quand même de
foucault sur le terrain politique et
n'hésitait pas à s'engager
1 et puis dans votre pratique me dit
qu'il aurait aimé avoir au collège de
france ou ailleurs à l'université une
chaire n'ont pas tiré le film est une
chaire de politique les bâtisses a
souvent c'est quand il ya dix ans quand
je les ai connus
c'était ça c'est assez compliqué il ya
une chose qu'il faut dire c'est que
c'était insuffisant et que à mon avis
plus difficile que les autres parce que
plus limpide par phrase et par page et
dans la pensée
si on voulait quand on veut on faire la
synthèse est assez disons finement
sophistiqué et est largement ramifié
donc au riz d'une culture immense
extraordinaire qui remettait constamment
en question puisque tout récemment et il
avait pensé qu'ils ne connaissaient rien
sur le sujet dont il avait parlé alors
sur les yeux de la politique il dit au
fond si mauvais on se référer pour faire
de la philosophie avant ceux qui osaient
variant parce qu'ils ne passaient pas à
ce qu'elle exhibe stands
il dit que la philosophie l'etna est
acculé à se demander qu'est ce qui se
passe et qui passe et qu'est-ce que nous
sommes dans le rapport avec ce qui se
passe nous qui passons
quelle est cette relation éphémère entre
une chose éphémère à naître et ce mr
c'est à dire que tous nos cours du
couvre que la philosophie est aussi à
l'aide d'une charge historique et
sociologique une appréhension de
l'instant
réfléchir seul instant et comment
réfléchir seul instant par la politique
et elie 10 et même par le journalisme
politique qui l'avait même à ce moment
je ne croyais en coquetterie l'admirer
tellement je plaçais signaux que quand
il disait qu'il a envié certes certaines
préoccupations ou jeu
jeunes égarés pendant l'interprétation
je ne croyais qu'une application voire
je crois pas non non pas c'est pas non
non parce que disons en termes alors si
vous voulez 2 de surface sociale ou de
relief
il avait une notoriété non je vais pas
me souvenir la chaîne j'ai vu quelque
part qu'il disait qu'il aurait aimé
diriger un journal politique sinon oui
oui je sais où aller où il parlait de
saab avant propos d'ailleurs mais mais
mais je ne crois pas que c'était la
direction puisque vous savez qu'il a
fait du journalisme
oui oui puis non mais pas seulement
régional il avait un contrat avec le
corriere della serra et un petit groupe
dont faisait partie glucksmann et puis à
la cigale cros et il faisait des
reportages dans le monde entier des
reportages dont je ne sais pourquoi il
ne voulait pas qu'on l'ait république il
dirigeait ses reportages
il a fait cette direction mais la façon
dont la philosophie s'épuisent pour lui
dans le politique ça ça a été un des
problèmes les plus importants de sa vie
si vous allez en gros il se réferrait
disait sartre ne m'a rien apporté
celui qui m'a le plus influencé c'est
vers le printemps à cause du passage de
la philosophie à la politique
merci jean meyniel alors donc les livres
de foucault sont pas tout ça mais enfin
vous pourrez le montrent les plus
importants voilà donc l'histoire de la
folie à l'âge classique de michel
foucault qui est parue la premier
édition 61 et la deuxième édition c'est
chez gallimard avec d'ailleurs une autre
préface naissance de la clinique
c'est auprès d'universitaires c'est je
crois quelques années après alors il ya
eu un raymond roussel dans la collection
le chemin de toujours de michel foucault
ne vivent assez curieux pts est
inattendue alors voici donc son temps
son grand livre les mots les choses et
mollets chose ça date de 1966 et publié
un bibliothèque des sciences humaines
chez gallimard
et puis l'archéologie du savoir la
conclusion c'est ça de valeur que josé
savoye de ces 1968 sépare de 1968
surveiller punir alors ça aussi c'est un
mec qui a fait beaucoup de bruit à
l'époque puisque c'est un livre sur la
prison toujours chez gallimard
alors là c'est l'histoire d'un parricide
moi pierre rivière ayant égorgé ma mère
ma soeur et mon frère dans la collection
archives
et puis alors voici les trois volumes
donc la volonté du savoir c'est le
premier volume de l'histoire de la
sexualité qui est paru en 76
et puis voici les deuxième et troisième
volume qui viennent donc de sortir au
moment où il est mort le deuxième volume
c'est l'usagé des plaisirs le troisième
volume le souci de soi
est-ce que vous pensez que il a laissé
de la suite de ce pays pierre nora avec
l'arrêt qui travaillaient sur le
quatrième tome qui n'est pas achevée
mais en partie selon son éditeur
très bien merci à tous